citizens of the reject Nation I bet
we're not the two faces you expected to
see today as Greg and Aaron Alexander
have been working their way through the
recent Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtle
movies produced by Michael Bay but it
just so turns out that they really know
the one we're about to cover today quite
well so that leaves you guys stuck with
Donatello and Leonardo today as we catch
up with TMNT
2007 the animated motion picture Andrew
are you excited
fasanova Chevy Nova excellent
wrong movie but you know we we endure
guys leave a like on this video and uh
also subscribe hit the notification Bell
to find out when there are more juicy
reactions for you to to ooze into your
life and uh as always we like to thank
the folks at prepper for cutting down
these for shredding these highlights uh
it's a it's tough work and we very much
appreciate them for it I'm really loving
these you haven't picked up on the
metaphor yes
Aaron's Michelangelo and Olivia's
Splinter we had a whole conference to
figure this out but uh Hey speaking of
conferences if you want to have one with
us come on over to patreon.com the real
rejects where you can also sync up with
your own copy of TMNT and enjoy the full
thing see everything that doesn't make
these reaction highlights it's a good
time over there Andrew you got anything
else to say before we hop into the sewer
Cowabunga I'm so excited to watch this I
can't wait heroes in a half shell roll
the bumper
thank you
yes
Bob and Harvey Weinstein let's give a
round of applause prolific
producing team oh boy
I didn't even realize they worked on
this
oh yeah that's a cool logo
four turtles
Four Brothers oh sweet loving the way
they're moving reborn in the sewers of
New York is that the Bowery king after
the Great Renaissance Masters
and shrinked as ninjas yeah
they battled many creatures and foes
before defeating their Arch Enemy the
shredder yeah buddy okay so he's been
defeated but now a greater evil is
poised to destroy their very Brotherhood
an evil born 3
000 years ago oh oh snap what could it
be the warrior king named Yao little
Brotherhood that fought side by side
with one purpose
to conquer all the kingdoms of the world
of course another purpose is there I
heard Raul Julia when you said that of
course line as they left a trail of
Destruction behind them
oh damn as they marched on Mordor I was
gonna say he's giving me a Lord of the
Rings Vibe it is not this day
yeah this is impressive this looks like
one of those gateway to the Mind's Eye
videos learned of a constellation known
as the stars of Keegan
every 3 000 years the Stars would align
tracking balls opening a portal to a
world of unknown power oh no
destroy the one ring
his Brotherhood was turned to stone now
13 monsters were released into our world
damn
all right they're the maximals this is
just every property
I'm really digging a lot of the tracking
shots
and the monsters that were Unleashed
continue to plague mankind wonder who's
gonna stop them
just have to wait and see it's okay I'll
stop
don't worry Andrew I got this we got
this yeah we're Donatello and Leonardo
we appreciate the generous donation for
the continued protection of your village
oh damn
after all the jungle can be a very
dangerous place so I remember in
Predator is it part of like the the
Hench warlord starter pack that you need
to be eating a knife or an apple with a
knife I was gonna say that's automatic
you're you're a villain when you're
doing that I remember that in Dennis the
Menace uh of course Swiss blade Sam I
believe his name was
God here you don't have to yell
whoa
attacking from the Shadows might be the
Predator definitely oh my God Turtles
versus Predator that'd be amazing we
need to write that
I just remembered
nice that's so cool enhances the
creature-like aspect yeah I mean I've
seen them in the shadows before but
blending into the environment like that
because of the same color that's awesome
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles using the
Shadows
we are far away from New York oh don't
worry we'll get there South America
dang take that and restore your city
the last Ronin
what's this April yeah it's April
wearing yellow do you know the ghost he
wasn't always a ghost well that voice
sounds familiar Sarah Michelle Geller
well done I'm going to assume you knew
that innately no I heard it I heard it
and just went Buffy
oh yeah
it's a long way from the city to just
drop in nice
actually I was already here on business
what kind of business ancient artifacts
I'm a Tomb Raider now much time on his
hands has his
uh oh our Strange crowd hasn't been the
same without you how bad could it be
Donny's probably got everything
troll what kind of a leader of payment
system
um the computer on have you plugged it
in yeah that would help oh let's see do
tech support don't just lean on your
keyboard though man's 101. well if he's
doing that who's keeping an eye on Mikey
Mike's gotten into the um is he pizza
delivery
I could have seen him doing pizza
delivering too
but this this is in line too I just love
that he's
effectively dressed in a costume of
himself
version of his own Visage
it kind of reminds me of ghostbusters 2
at the beginning when they're dressed
kind of as themselves
sleeps all day
oh yeah kicks asses and runs out of
bubble gum
damn Greg is so cool I like how they
have to put the the text in there as if
we don't know
for the noobs and ah I mean this in a
good way this looks like a video game I
would like to play
I thought it was gonna be and we didn't
make a lot of noise too
it's an inspiration to
do it that guy's voice isn't like
everything is that Jim come Kim Cummings
maybe your guess is as good as mine
Andrew
what's going on guys
oh with the chain
looks like it's just you and me Shady
you're in the wrong line of work
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
that's a cool like it's more fun that
way yeah it's hotter that way I do like
the design of that suit he's wearing
it's kind of like the Mewtwo armor these
people need me more than my brothers do
that's never true never abandoned family
yeah your brothers need you Leo
lost without you
Leah whoa he pulled a Batman in front of
her too that's impressive
Cowabunga Carl just going with the now
we see where are they came up with
Arnold Schwarzenegger's name for Carl
and the new Terminator film Donna fate
it was from this there you go The
Unofficial fifth Turtle Arnold
when you can skate a sewer pipe yeah
my thoughts exactly
[Applause]
dude I'm loving the cinematography this
is taking me back to my skateboard days
man and I want to bust out the board now
dude I was always playing Tony Hawk on
n64. one of my favorite games of all
time yes
[Music]
that was awesome dude
Flawless dang got a sewer cave
here's Mikey yeah I understood that
reference As Good As It Gets right
definitely definitely it's actually
um
all the presidents we will get comments
saying are you kidding you didn't know
that the Vigilante known as night
watcher strikes again I remember how
they used to feel busting up crime
syndicates sure they had a bunch of guns
but they weren't like these guns yeah
yeah some tickets forget about him get
on with your life concentrate on your
work yeah your career
oh I suppose you think the night
Watcher's some kind of hero
a little sort of you think fear is the
best way to accomplish things but you're
wrong first of all you speak of doesn't
exist anymore
oh yeah
yeah you know it's interesting seeing
Donny take up the Leo role right now
yeah he's got a big mantle Andrew a lot
of responsibility you must learn to be
strong when they week
if you don't learn to recognize this
then all hope is lost for our family oh
family man I love Mako dude there was a
film that he was in called uh taking
care of business with James Belushi and
Charles Grodin so good gotta check that
was JJ Abrams first written film ooh
take a note
as old school
Casey old school cell phone where you at
CJ
a lot of old school phones
it's broken the
that's gonna say if it starts going off
now it's not gonna help you
that is a very cool structure this place
a museum or what
State Technology Pharmaceuticals they
must be the good guys they are
definitely the good guys just
break all this stuff careful
ah that still hurts
[Music]
Christ
oh boy please tell me that wasn't you it
was the crates so technically it wasn't
him I
would be great if Leo was in there but
he's not a doubt I believe this is the
one they call General Aquila it's
actually Aguila I thought that was a
good try a gila and the Bee these
statues may appear to be only Stone
but they're like family to me is that
Patrick Stewart it's Patrick Stewart
Andrew
but it's still I know yeah it still gets
you like my heart seizes up feeling
tension could you make it fast I've got
a shareholders
with 10 I'd rather
the building like elevates
already
about to say is that the foot well it's
not the hand Andrew that is how they
came up with that idea though I'm sure
you knew that oh co-enlighten me I have
some friends coming to town that I'd
like to roll out the red carpet for some
ancient friends bring them to me and how
will we know these friends
friends don't worry they're impossible
to miss there are 13 of them they're
monsters that narrows it down in New
York I I assume it's been a while since
we saw those guys
a very Sinister belch that actually was
a pretty creepy way to reintroduce that
yeah they've been lurking all this time
go catch you calling the cops
I love these just like chain Spider-Man
mixed with Robo Batman
hope I'm not disturbing class hey
I got this one covered pal
you may have everyone else fooled but
you haven't fooled me wrath guess what
now rafman V Casey Jones dawn of Justice
I think they're missing is the rain
he's trying to get away
and that guy looks like both Flint Marco
and the guy who shot Uncle Ben
that's funny I think that's the look
they were going for what is it
performance art
always sit around wait for Leo to come
back and save the day you got your New
Yorker Turtle too we were talking about
this off camera I love it the criminal
element of this city made me guilty of a
lot of things but being quitters ain't
one of them
you know I don't even care about Leo
anymore I hope he never comes back I
hope he never makes another film
[Music]
sweet
don't worry Andrew he's going to use
these things for good definitely I would
never guess this man is evil
Patrick Stewart he can't name one time
uh Prince of Egypt pharaoh
recently all the generals wake from your
stone slumber
oh no
trans Latin American we got a little Leo
on here yeah
they say humans can't survive in the
wheel well the King has returned they
never say anything about a turtle
whoa nice so perspective it's Mission
Impossible this I was gonna say
Captain America like a winter soldier
but that works too also Captain America
winter sold whatever you want
that was smooth like the ocean under the
moon and the emotion that I get from you
you got the kind of love and that could
be so smooth Andrew or else forget about
all right I'm done
um you've grown
become independent because until you can
act as one
you are forbidden to fight oh what
I've missed you Leonardo hmm
oh Father Oh Daddy hey
welcome home it's like my name's night
watcher now
hey Leo's back
to say hello before he leaves again
you're just hurt
I'm like dreaming aren't I no you're not
you're not dreaming oh good I have
nightmares about birthday parties
oh no Tears of a Clown this night
watcher characters come into the
neighborhood like some kind of vigilante
Showboat the night watcher was the only
guy to pick up the slack crime never
took a break you did carefully deeply
about that oh my God you're so smart why
don't we have jetpacks
Mikey I don't
even driver's license
I mean he's done okay so far
today
I must say he was gonna say crane
crane I mean smell that it's like a
monkey cage up here
a monkey cage
not kicked out of them yeah
you think we should help these guys I'd
rather enjoy the show we stopped talking
uh is Leo's not allowed to fight is he I
I mean no that's directive he was given
we'll see how he applies that for the
wrong foot here
get it that's the wrong foot man
wait the Shredder's Dead
who are you working for but is he go get
real jobs
oh no
like I said too easy
so many cartoon spleens in Peril I've
noticed that is insane that is a very
cool shot yeah this is why we need jet
packs yeah I'm with Mikey hashtag get
them jet packs
oh that reminds me of Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles 2 when the Super Shredder
it comes down on him do you remember or
secret of these have I seen The Secret
of the I don't know if I've seen if I if
I've seen it I do not remember I was
gonna say I hope I didn't spoil it for
you it's okay it's the greatest ending
to a turtle's movie ever all right
go ninja our entire audience just
groaned
go ninja go ninja go
what's y'all got
rap
yeah
oh yeah the turtles are back dudes I
give us a 10 for style is the building I
Collapse
oh yeah
thought they were setting it up for that
it's okay yeah this could have gotten
much worse All Things Considered true we
made a deal Karai and I expect you to
honor it and what is your name
Greg show these fools how a true warrior
Acts we do not need any help I trust my
family more than I trust you ah now
micromanage them they will help you
gather the remaining 12 of these
Abominations so we can finally see how
birthright's fulfilled
to be quite a party
sounds like it's gonna work well for you
in particular weird
mom dude the cereal is just called
cereal yeah we gotta watch the product
placement here of course it's like Repo
Man the first movie was Domino's
oh good morning my sons
I would love to hear some Splinter songs
I would too this is the most Charming
part of the day I'll be watching my
stories
what does Master Splinter watch I want
to know probably likes the movie Wilfred
you mean Willard Willard there you go
Leonardo I am most disappointed in you
we cannot return to the surface to fight
evil if we continue to fight each other
how can I be expected in Tucson no
excuses when you are the leader do not
Question Master Splinter
Wayne Enterprises can't believe he's a
bad guy in this universe yeah dude
Batman vs Ninja Turtles though excellent
I still haven't seen it oh Andrew it's
one of the best
[Applause]
jeez Warriors are doing a pretty good
job actually
it's clobbering time yeah
[Music]
whoa
whoa these are like nightmares yeah I'm
taking him to the SCP
ten down three to go don't just stand on
the Aztec calendar like that or the
Mayan counter whichever one's the end of
the world one
dang April honing her martial arts hey
Casey
Ralph meet me on the roof okay what is
it you know what the roof is it's the
top part of the building but that's not
important right now
do stress amateur
this cameraman sucks as if we couldn't
tell
really is good animation though
come on
I agree it's like the animation isn't
the most like obviously modern or
complex but the way they're using it is
really effective and evocative still
well that was one of the things that
turned me off from seeing it originally
but I'm I'm
pleasantly surprisingly enjoying I love
it so far in the cinematography
ah I hope you had monster insurance
no you kind of failed to tell me about
that one buddy
you do know I only have a wooden bed
that's plenty yeah you're Casey Jones
so the pun sets itself what I thought
they were history I mean they're living
history
can statues
no don't take them
[Music]
the police
uh it's really cool like saber tooth
detailing there
oh oh No Sleep gone what happened to
Raph I
I later on they'll use that to plug out
of The Matrix
whoa
this sort of stone take this to the lab
and do some investigation looks South
American that's your department April
that those statues you collected for
that Winter's guy were shooting these
things at me and RAF this is all your
fault 3 000 years ago some
great warrior actually found a portal to
another dimension The Greatest Warrior
the energy from it gave the warrior
eternal life but it also turned his
generals to Stone oh do you think that's
Patrick Stewart's character uh uh yeah
of course should have seen that coming
this has Winter's name written all over
it w how do you figure that Donnie
because this has Winter's name written
all over it
it's very smart have a villain to put
his name on something like that if
you've got something you want to get off
your shell Now's the Time but I'm not
gonna stand here and debate Splinter's
direct orders with you fine
I quit
go to Shell you know having the writing
on the dirt is almost as smart as Peter
Parker having his name on the camera and
the Andrew Garfield Amazing Spider-Man
and lizard discovered it was him I'm
like that was brilliant let's finish it
and you will finally be free of your
stone prison what if the curse is broken
we will no longer be immortal do not
question my command and you're lucky to
be alive right now are they going to
disobey him at some point they're gonna
turn good and then get regular jobs and
live amongst New Yorkers
God's brother has plans to be
the 13th monster must not be found ah
bury it
[Music]
playing myself this sounds a little like
the Matrix now slapping the bass
oh is this the 13th monster
it's probably a cat
you're the cute guy
[Music]
okay that was different
yes he's like the animated version of
salacious crumb
s
truly a monster how about a snack
whoa
it's concentrated habanero peppers take
everything I'm not even looking
your life
yeah I just love that this guy is still
talking in the background
that's such an iconic shot yeah
let's go we got some issues to work out
oh it's on
go
huh
play these little camera movements so
I'm gonna give you
and do vigilante stuff as a team with us
okay
now we've got our Batman v Superman uh
Rainey shots yes
hit him with the sound waves trust me
when I tell you you don't want to do
this
oh yeah well I noticed you got quite a
temper
I mean yeah it's one of his defining
characters
oh ow there's nothing like repairing a
relationship and fighting and beating
each other into submission that's a life
experience we all should have someday
the fist fight that ends though is say
Martha of course
oh
uppercut that what
ah funk you can't leave home and come
back expecting us to fall in line again
like your little soldier yeah
you're impatient and hot tempered and
more importantly
better than you oh no I'd have to
disagree with you on that one ah
all right let's see
around one fight around two I guess
oh my goodness
oh handheld flourishes and stuff so
winner gets to be the leader right yep
oh no
jeez
dude kill him kill your brother do it
that was a great fight though yeah man I
was gripped by that and there was so
much emotion behind it too I forgot I
was forgot I was in the room kind of now
I kind of wish Batman v Superman felt
like that in the fight
what do you mean Andrew oh I know it's
it's a briefly a perfect fight oh no I
still love that movie but yeah wish I
would have felt more in that moment
oh
God hell of a time for Raph to just run
off by the time our brother discovers
this typical it's not the 13th monster
he
me interesting plan
[Music]
ah see when it counts man
if you weren't wearing all that gear you
could have caught them no
no you may not be my favorite student it
does not mean that you are my least
favorite son oh you are strong that
passionate and loyal to a fault these
are the merits of a great leader as well
as a lovely sentiment I missed a big
tonight Splinter the wise
no no
they took them
yep it's okay this is your Agent Coulson
moment all right we need Casey Jones we
need April let's all hands on deck yeah
let's get the whole team we must return
to the surface to take back what is ours
we must go out of the Shadows
I like this like steampunk South
American aesthetic Central American
aesthetic this is the director's cut of
the Lions Gate main bumper
yes
suit up
I got it on my lap nice April April
looks like
ride how would you know Andrew ever seen
it but I've seen what the character
looks like John you can't go
trick-or-treating that is a sick mask
thanks you go trick-or-treating with me
this year you've got to be kidding me
dude is that Kate that's Casey yeah
oh no
yeah it's interesting seeing the
different family conflicts on both the
good guys and the bad guys yeah
it's also interesting just whizzing past
all of the cosmos
but they said one day every 3 000 years
right something like that all the
planets go into retrograde and up
your life
oh
oh it's an ancient 3 000 year old Sky
beam we have to find that 30 monster
it's time to end it oh cool
oh time is just beginning it's time to
end you brother sound like Megatron
whoa look at April getting in on it yeah
well we did see her
she's training she's thrown down she's a
Tomb Raider now and a martial artist
among other things
this is a cool tracking shot yeah
gotta get you a winner you know who
directed this shot right who Alejandro
yeah
entreat who's Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles I would love to see that all
that natural light boy
[Music]
pop punked a new metal
oh like guys give me another 20 minutes
I'm having a good dream yeah let me
recharge off some of this cosmic energy
here
he's got new katanas yes katanas excuse
me Andrew I mispronounced really
insensitive how dare me you're gonna
need these if you're gonna lead us out
of here
yeah
it's good to see through United
I had pretty hard I'm seeing giant
turtles yeah we know what you're up to
is he really surprised to see things
like that I must return all 13 beasts or
our curse will continue and that is a
torment I can no longer bear
not you guys join us Foot Clan Square
Your Allegiance to us and no harm will
be for you the food ninja is not without
honor we work for Winters not you oh
damn I mean we're probably gonna get an
annihilator right now but we work for
Winters
oh
please they can defeat them they are a
team
let's send them back where they belong
let's go
nice wow
oh and they're paired off with ones that
match
come to death
oh my God use every sword you know
you should join us
splinter
[Music]
hurry with that last monster yeah I'm
sure
that's what I'm afraid of nah Casey
saves the daisy
hello
nice
there's some teamwork for you back to
Dimension X I know they didn't go there
but I had to throw the reference in
foolish creatures
[Music]
to break our curse we will never be
stopped funny you should say that wrap
them in paper
oh yeah
[Music]
scoots right in that was very well timed
I like it ah Wowie
ah back to your physical forms for about
a moment or your organic form
wow
Sky beam
not that I wanted them to interfere but
I'm surprised no police converged on
that location where the Big Sky beam was
going
ah
oh
hey hey there we will have further
business together the kind of involved
familiar faces from your past Shredder
oh good Shredder she doesn't mean
Baxter Stockman
uh will you marry me
and thank you
Brothers
oh
dang whoa
[Music]
interesting wow he's one with the force
now he is
pure essence
the night watcher retires
Oh look The TG all right secret oh
straight oh my God we've got relics oh
my goodness it is in in the universe and
the Teenage Mutant Ninja three the the
light the thing that helped them go back
in time
oh there's the night watcher
oh my God I'm pretty sure that's the
helmet from it's either the first or the
second movie
[Applause]
I say that goes up on there oh my God
Stalker should wear that those Easter
eggs on that wall huh let's go
we are ninjas
strike hard
defend protected no mercy yeah I was
gonna say strike first no mercy
this is uh where Johnny Lawrence learned
to jumping off the buildings that's
right I love
it yeah yeah buddy Cowabunga says it all
not bad I really enjoyed it yeah and
then what happened to Lawrence Fishburne
I guess Raphael just bust into the booth
and was like I'm narrating this now
was that Lawrence Fishburn at the very
beginning oh my God not not doing the
voice of Rafael no no no no I know but I
didn't even yeah picking up everyone
else's voice I must have missed that one
like no you know this was really good I
mean first of all the cinematography the
animation the score very very well done
I was really like just from a filmmaking
perspective just really engulfed into it
yeah but I actually really enjoy oh
class bedel loved him Pirates of the
Caribbean the first one and then Hans
Zimmer took over um but I really enjoyed
the inner conflict obviously you know
whenever you get a Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtle storyline you're going to get the
inner conflicts of the family Dynamic of
course that's just standard routine but
I thought like you know for something
that's been done so many times I really
enjoyed the whole thing about him going
to Central America to become a better
leader because that's how I mean
Leonardo's has always been my favorite I
I love all four of them equally but
maybe it's everyone's maybe it's safe
maybe it's because it's the color blue I
don't know but Leo's always been my
favorite and I never thought in the
films at least the earlier ones uh
specifically the first two the 1990 and
1991 films I didn't think he was Chris
Evans oh it's Chris Evans okay for some
reason I thought it was Freddie Prince I
was like it's not sounding like Freddie
Prince
um
um but uh yeah I just didn't oh my god
oh he was the cook that's awesome
catch that
um oh no but I didn't think in those
first two movies I promise we'll get
this point out
Lawrence Fishman hey Larry fish yeah but
in the in the first two uh films I
didn't think that uh they did a and
Nolan North John Dimas oh my goodness
all these voice
D Baker yes so many people Billy West
yeah
um I I wasn't the biggest fan of how
Leonardo was utilized in terms of the
leader in the first two films per se
so I I just love this whole idea of him
going to Central America to become a
better leader uh you know to help in
terms of the family Dynamic and to be
the the turtle we all wanted him to be
so and then you know the way Rafael was
just
felt that he was more of an abandonment
towards the family and just didn't want
to you know go along with that and then
the juxtaposed to the position of the
winter side where it's like they're
having their own inner conflict family
so I just I thought that was really
interesting the way they they did all
that but what'd you think of the film I
I quite enjoyed it very much so I agree
with pretty much everything you have
said up till this point I mean yeah this
was
A really lovely kind of fun reminder
that yeah just something like that like
there's I feel like there's a lot of
solid Turtle media out there and this
was something that was obviously not
super long it's kind of compact but also
never felt rushed and it always felt in
the spirit of at least what I associate
with the Ninja Turtles but I like two
that were kind of off in a side pocket
universe or something that doesn't feel
like it's you know I'm excited for the
new movie because there's so much Turtle
lore and recognizable characters
um and I'm sure aspects of this you know
are are still encompassing of of various
other Turtle media but it was cool to
kind of see something that was sort of
existing on its own terms and that yeah
hones in on those classic elements of
them as a family but also has a pretty I
think neat turn with the villains like I
love this whole like it looks like you
know pretty much like a Sauron scenario
startup where it's like yeah this
all-powerful Warrior and his Unstoppable
Army you know finds the key to
immortality and then the turn that comes
by the end I thought was great because
you have Patrick Stewart and you have
the fun of like oh he's playing a
villain awesome but then you have the
perspective of time in him being like Oh
I lost everything and they they you know
foreshadow that nicely at the beginning
um and I just didn't see it coming that
that Despair and that perspective would
kind of make him a more well-adjusted
character to the point where he would be
like oh you know what I do need to find
these creatures not to harness their
power but yeah to fix all this and then
you know I Winters will except the
winter of my life and you know fade off
Into Obscurity and so yeah as a story
about them putting the family back
together and repairing these you know
brotherly conflicts
and then you know also
stopping this unbeatable Force I thought
it was just really well drawn and
it's like a good amount of time was
spent with all the characters I mean
April probably is like of all the
prominent Turtle care it's like I feel
like you spend more time with Casey in
this
um April's still like badass and very
capable but she's not as much of like
the most engaged character as I was
expecting maybe especially having Sarah
Michelle Geller on The Voice
um but yeah I mean like gripes for me on
this would be very few and far between
and yeah like you were we were talking
about the animation and it's like this
isn't the most state-of-the-art
animation I've ever seen certainly
um but I just thought the way that they
expressed it the way they used it it's
like even though there are times where
you're like yeah like these could be
more detailed or more realistic looking
it never took away from it they always
had a really great sense of motion and
just imagery like it felt like well
informed by the graphic novels and stuff
like that and the other media you know
the live action stuff too
um and there's so many sequences that
again even though you're watching
something that's a bit fun and Whimsical
still pack a punch you know yeah I know
and there were a lot of iconic shots too
just like with them in the shadows uh
Leo like blending in camouflage in the
jungle
um kind of did actually remind me a
little bit of the Predator also too just
going back to that reference where I
said Casey was like Captain America
jumping into the water yeah it's funny
it was Chris Evans who's voice again
like yeah it was Captain America but no
you make it you didn't know that I
really did it was the reference I really
didn't know it was great I actually I
was under the impression it was uh oh
David goyer worked on that stuff uh I
was I was under the impression it was
Again The Voice wasn't hitting me I'm
like why is this Frame Prince Junior it
doesn't sound like Freddie Prince Jr
um I thought it was Freddie Prince Jr
before we had started the film I didn't
look at the cast
um I always had known Sarah Michelle
Geller was in this but I did not know
any of the other voice casts but I
didn't hear Chris Evans so when I had
said that I really was just making a
Captain America reference without
knowing was Chris Evans I do love the
point that you make about winters though
like because when we saw him we're like
oh this must be the bad guy I mean I
thought it was just going to be some
generic type bag and also I'm not gonna
lie and I know people in the comments
are are gonna people in the comments are
gonna say we've seen Shredder done today
of course obviously I would have loved
to have seen Shredder that would have
been great especially in the vein of
this film
but the way they went about winters like
you said were like you know I at first I
mean I thought he was gonna just use
these care I mean yeah I know he wanted
to you know I I thought like you was
going to harness these characters like
trying to harness their powers and not
understand like no he just wants to be
free of this curse and like yeah I just
thought like it's a lot deeper than I
was expecting and I was not I'm just
like Shell Shocked without no plan that
they that they went that route but it
was I was pleasantly surprised I was
like okay this is again I always like
shre you know Shredder Bebop Rocksteady
crying Baxter but
I was rather moved by the storyline they
went with with this villain because
again I was just a generic rich bad guy
I want to use this power and harness it
somehow for my nefarious D's and like
this was actually surprisingly well done
yeah and I mean one supported the other
because yeah it's like you know there
are iconic characters that you maybe
Miss from this but personally just as
again I kind of expect to see all these
people now in any Turtle thing uh unless
it's an offshoot so this being sort of a
moment I believe this was like the first
uh CG animated and theatrically released
animated CG Turtles movie or whatever
and it seems like you would want to make
this a bit of a punctuation point and so
yeah it's like even though I personally
really like that they were at the
beginning they were like we vanquished
Shredder we've done that and and that's
settled and now we're moving on to
something totally different and and yeah
it's like even though I wouldn't want
this to be like forever and never see
Shredder again I was happy that we got
to do something that clears the way
especially you know this was made in
2007 so the sensibility is a little bit
different and it's allowed to Just
Breathe as a story not that that's not
that there's anything wrong with the
more kinetic styles of the here and now
and the more referential uh style of the
here and now but yeah I like that it was
contained to that and they did create
this hierarchy of like you had Winters
who became something of an actual
character who had a story with his
warriors uh that mirrors or at least
complements what's going on between the
turtles because they can't resolve their
family squabble either and they can't
see eye to eye
um and you know I I bought even though
the stone Warriors aren't really that
well fleshed out or anything like that
you know I still bought their whole
thing of like well we just got you've
been here this whole time we just came
back to life but we're also like these
red-eyed Stone beasts and so you know
you get the more overt villainy from
where they're coming from and then the
monsters are just
just behaving by their nature and so
they create the fun and games of all
that I I don't even think it was to your
point I don't think it was necessary to
flesh out those I got the point pretty
quickly and just through winters like I
could kind of see where they were going
with that anyways but um I also too just
again getting back to the whole family
Dynamic too I I really enjoyed the
relationship that we saw between Casey
and Raphael you know whenever Raphael
felt there was nothing he could do uh in
terms of relating anything of his
frustrations uh per se to his family he
could always go back to Casey yeah so
and I love that they have that type of
relationship uh also too there was that
one scene where Rafael uh you know felt
he had failed be after Leo had been
captured and then you have that great
moment with uh yeah Sensei Splinter uh
just telling him you know the whole
thing about hey you might not be one of
my favorite students but that does not
mean you're not one of my favorite songs
like that was crazy but like at the end
of the day just like yes he's he's their
teacher but he's their father too so
yeah and I just I love that they really
were able to execute on the family
Dynamic and that's for me I mean yes
look I love the fighting I love when
they go up against Shredder crying and
all these dudes of course that's that's
the but to me the heart of the turtles
is the family Dynamic and when you can
nail that all the other stuff is just
it's icing on the cake for me oh yeah I
mean there's stuff that about this that
could be more fleshed out but in the in
the hierarchy of priorities I thought
they got everything right and yeah the
family stuff it gives you all the
tensions you want you get to watch them
fight a little bit but then yeah you get
some heartfelt moments you get some
moments that really are true to the
cores of the characters and yeah you get
your whole night uh stalker thing or
whatever reason I watch night watcher
um you know which does to me kind of
hearken to some of that Ronin stuff too
and then yeah it's like you have the
stuff with Karai and you have the foot
and and they're not really characters
that much but it's fun to have the foot
kind of semi-fighting alongside and yeah
that's uh uh
now is uh the name below Mitchell
Whitfield do you recognize that actor uh
uh oh
he's uh Ralph Macchio's buddy who got a
uh he was um under uh arrest with uh
Ralph Macchio oh okay sweet in that yeah
so okay yeah yeah sure sure I recognize
him now he's like what about everything
we
you're fired I want him oh the the cat
the voice casting this so good I really
I mean I haven't and mako's Splinter I
really enjoyed him as well um I have not
looked into it I don't think there was a
sequel if there was let us know in the
comments but I don't believe there was
which to me is actually really sad
because I would have loved to have seen
a sequel in this particular Universe
obviously I know we got so many
different media mediums of uh Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles which I'm so
grateful for but I would have loved to
have continued on in this universe per
se I mean this I really really enjoyed
this and again like I said coming into
this
I was so disappointed uh in Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles 3 and at the time I
was only five and I'm still disappointed
I will say this I I've not I have not
told many people of hardly anyone ever
knows this and this is not a Meek
loading thing but one positive thing
came in to get a little off topic one
positive thing came out of Teenage
Mutant Ninja three there was a scene in
that movie I forgot which Turtle might
have been Raphael who gave CPR to the
kid who had like he was uh from
uh breathing in Smoke from fire yeah you
couldn't breathe anymore and Raphael
gave him mouth-to-mouth CPR the point
anyways I'm trying to make the point I'm
trying to make my mother when I was six
years old was running out of breath
and I remember what I had seen from that
movie and I had I was give I gave her
CPR and I I saved her life and now uh I
in the amount of time I was doing the
CPR was enough time for the ambulance to
get there and they told me I saved her
life and my mother asked me uh when she
was like able you know functioning and
able to talk again she's like how did
you know how to do it I said from
because Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles 3.
so as much as I bag on that movie I I
will always be grateful for that there's
my little uh off topic tidbit for the
day but um again coming into this movie
like I said when I saw the trailer and
the promos I'm like I I want to see an
anime but I want to I want rectification
you know I want Redemption for Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles no not that but I
just wanted a live action film so I
didn't give this one a chance I would
which was not fair on me but on the flip
side I'm glad I got to react to it with
you I know but I I stuck with me I
actually did mess up because I I really
did enjoy it's actually one of my
favorite versions I know it's really uh
I I just fresh off watching it so I
might not feel this way tomorrow but
it's one of my favorite versions of
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles seriously I
really
I really mean that I I really enjoy the
heck out of this yeah it was really good
well guys what did you think of TMNT
2007 leave your thoughts down below as
well as any other Turtle related media
you'd like us to check out provided we
haven't already seen it or something
like that uh like subscribe keep a
follow on Andrew wherever he watch watch
Andrew most at the real rejects but also
watch him wherever else he might pop up
on the internet I could think of maybe
one or two channels and hey before we
get out of here why don't we shout out a
patron Mikhail Lyndon you were chosen
for a very special purpose
because we figure out which Turtle you
would be Andrew who like who is he in
our Turtle Club right now who is Mikhail
Lyndon well I mean what is the only
possible choice we have all four turtles
taken already but if I had to substitute
him for one he's mccraying is that what
you're saying that's what I'm saying you
got it you got it you read my mind yes
by as always John
think you know which one I'm thinking I
think we all definitely you're Mikhail
oh you're Michaela Tello you're
mccabriel O'Neil I like that one we're
gonna get to everybody except for the
person you think we're trying to show
obviously Casey Jones I like these these
are good yeah man he's master
splendon
splenden
he's anyway Mikhail we love you and uh
we would uh uh roll around in any kind
of ooze if you told us to uh you know
you are much like a Master Splinter in
that you keep us grounded with your
wisdom and your calm energy and uh you
know you're also like Shredder because I
imagine that you know how to use Cutlery
and can really play a mean guitar and uh
and hey regardless of whatever else I
think we can all agree that pizza is
great so this shout out has gone
swimmingly love you buddy keep your
Pledge on file and we'll catch you next
month hope you're doing well out there
and uh Cowabunga dude
Christmas
[Music]